foreign
but if you judge a fish by its ability
to climb a tree it will live its whole
life believing that it is stupid
the most incomprehensible thing about
the world is that it is comprehensible
education is what remains after one has
forgotten what one has learned in school
science is a wonderful thing if you do
not need to earn your living from it
[Music]
when you trip over love it is easy to
get up but when you fall in love it is
impossible to stand again
blind belief in Authority is the
greatest enemy of Truth
is an illusion
imagination is everything it is the
preview of life's coming attractions
genius is one percent talent and 99 hard
work
[Music]
we all know that light travels faster
than sound that's why certain people
appear to be bright until you hear them
speak
there are only two ways to live your
life one as if nothing is a miracle
the other is as if everything is a
miracle
whoever is careless with the truth in
small matters cannot be trusted with
important matters
the measure of intelligence is the
ability to change
a smart person solves a problem
a wise person avoids the problem
if you want your children to be smart
read fairy tales to them
if you want them to be smarter read more
fairy tales to them
the world is a dangerous place to live
not because of the people who are evil
but because of the people who don't do
anything about the evil
life is like riding a bicycle to keep
your balance you have to keep moving
I believe in one thing only a life lived
for others is worth living
the main thing is not to stop asking
questions
curiosity is its own reason for being
look deep into nature and then you will
understand everything better
[Music]
all religions Arts and Sciences are
branches of the same tree
table chair fruit bowl and violin what
else does a person need to be happy
learn from yesterday Live today hope for
tomorrow
the main thing is not to stop asking
questions
he who can no longer stop to Marvel and
be in awe is as good as dead his eyes
are closed
a happy person is too content with the
present to think too much about the
future
strive not for success but for being
valuable
I talk to everyone the same way whether
it's a scavenger or a university
president
the best way to cheer yourself up is to
cheer somebody else up
when you are courting a nice girl an
hour seems like a second when you sit on
a red-hot cinder a second seems like an
hour
that's relativity
the most beautiful experience we can
have is the mysterious
there are a few who see with their eyes
and feel with their hearts
[Music]
I believe in the standardization of cars
I do not believe in the standardization
of people
[Music]
man should look for what is not for what
he thinks should be
great spirits have always met Fierce
resistance from mediocre Minds
a man who has never made a mistake has
never tried anything new
try not to become a successful person
rather try to become a valuable person
[Music]
the greatest scientists are also artists
intellectuals solve problems Geniuses
prevent them
[Music]
will seek revenge strong people forgive
smart people ignore
[Music]
a quiet and modest life brings more
happiness than the pursuit of success
combined with constant anxiety
[Music]
science can only flourish in an
atmosphere of free speech
[Music]
I would teach peace not War I would
instill love not hate
the world as we have created it is the
process of our thinking it cannot be
changed without changing our thinking
[Music]
I don't have much talent I'm just
passionately curious
[Music]
if you can't explain it to a
six-year-old you don't understand it
yourself
[Music]
logic will guide you from a to z
imagination can take you anywhere
[Music]
never memorize what you can look up
science without religion is lame
religion without science is blind
any fool can know the point is to
understand
you will never fail until you stop
trying
[Music]
gravity is not to blame for people
falling in love
it's not that I'm that smart I just stay
with questions much longer
[Music]
things are infinite the universe and
human stupidity
and I'm not sure about the universe
[Music]
everything must be made as simple as
possible
but not simpler
what is right is not always popular what
is popular is not always right
[Music]
The Pursuit Of Truth and beauty is a
sphere of activity in which we are
permitted to remain children all our
lives
if a is success in life then a equals X
Plus y plus Z
X's work Y is play and Z is keeping your
mouth shut
peace cannot be kept by force it can
only be achieved by understanding
in the middle of difficulty lies
opportunity
I'm thankful for all those who said no
to me
because of them I'm doing it myself
common sense is the collection of
prejudices acquired by age 18.
education is not the study of facts it's
more like training the mind to think
we can't solve our problems with the
same mindset we used when we created
them
[Music]
marriage makes people treat each other
like property not like Free People
marriage is nothing but slavery designed
to appear civilized
[Music]
Women Marry men hoping they will change
men marry women hoping they won't change
so everyone is bound to be disappointed
women always worry about things that men
forget men always worry about things
women remember
there comes a time when the mind takes a
higher plane of knowledge but could
never prove how it got there
the only source of knowledge is
experience
[Music]
you can think for months and years 99
times the conclusion is false the
hundredth time I am right
[Music]
the difference between genius and
stupidity is that genius has its limits
[Music]
the moon doesn't disappear when we're
not looking at it
[Music]
concern for man and his Destiny should
always be the main interest of all
technical efforts never forget this in
your diagrams and equations
[Music]
weakness of attitude becomes weakness of
character
[Music]
intelligent fool can make things bigger
and more complex
it takes a touch of genius and a lot of
courage to move in the opposite
direction
once you stop learning you start dying
the only thing that prevents me from
studying is my education
I must be willing to give up what I am
in order to become what I will be
the only thing more dangerous than
ignorance is arrogance
anger dwells only in the bosom of fools
mankind invented the atomic bomb but no
mouse will ever make a mouse trap
live with purpose don't let people or
things around you upset you
[Music]
to be respected stay away from ignorant
people
stay away from negative people they have
a problem for every solution
a man who has no roots anywhere is a
stranger everywhere
once we accept our limitations we
transcend them